sử trình đúng khi mà em bé bị sốt Cao co giật
cái điều quan
trọng nhất mà bà cần phải lưu ý là bà phải hết sức bình tĩnh
hết sức bình tĩnh bà không cần phải gọi AI cả
không cần phải gọi nhiều người đến
bởi vì càng gọi nhiều người
mọi người lại càng rối lên mà làm Sai
việc quan trọng đầu tiên là mình bình tĩnh
và sau đó để em bé trên một cái mặt phẳng cứng
để em bé trên mặt phẳng cứng nhá
nếu như mà lúc đấy rối quá không
không cứng được thì mềm cũng được không SAO
miễn là nó là mặt phẳng nhá
sau khi để em bé trên mặt phẳng cứng
thì sẽ để em bé nằm nghiêng
mục đích nằm nghiêng
để Cho những cái dịch nó không tràn vào phổi
không gây tắc nét đồ hấp của em bé nhá
một Tay và giữ vai
một Tay và giữ mông đó chỉ cần giữ nhẹ nhàng thôi
không được ghi chặt xuống
ghi chặt xuống em bé nó dãy rụa và nó khó thở
nó không thở được là không được nhá
chỉ nhẹ nhàng này thôi
sau đấy là loại bỏ
tất cả những cái thứ xung quanh của em bé
những cái thứ mà nó nhất là những cái vật sắc nhọn
việc thứ BA bà nên làm đó là bà nới lỏng quần áo Ra
cởi quần áo Ra đó nới
lỏng Ra nếu mà quần áo đang chật
nới lỏng Ra Cho em bé nó cảm thấy dễ chịu
sau đó để yên
để yên Cho em bé nó giật thoải mái đi được không
hết năm phút thì em bé nó sẽ hết giật
sốt Cao qua giật em bé nó chỉ giật trong vòng năm phút thôi
nhưng mà trong lúc nó giật ấy
bà sẽ quan sát cái kiểu giật của nó để khi mà
nếu như mà hết năm phút em bé nó vẫn chưa hết giật
có nghĩa là bà cần phải đưa em bé đến cơ sở y tế gần nhất
nếu như bà gọi một một năm mà không được ấy
thì bà phải tự mình đưa em bé đi
trong lúc mà đưa em bé đi ấy
thì bà cũng phải bế em bé nằm nghiêng như này
nằm nghiêng Ra ngoài nhá
không được bế nằm nghiêng vào trong lòng của mình đâu
không được bế em bé nằm nghiêng trong lòng của mình đâu
nằm nghiêng Ra ngoài như này
để Cho cái đờm rãi chảy Ra ngoài
và bà có thể quan sát được em bé
nó đang trong tình trạng như nào
sau khi đến cơ sở y tế gần nhất
thì sẽ mô tả Cho bác sĩ biết cái kiểu giật của em bé
để loại trừ những cái bệnh lý khác nó có nhá
đấy còn nếu như mà trong cái lúc mà ở nhà ấy
trong cái lúc ở nhà nếu như có AI đó ở xung quanh ấy thì
bảo người ta lấy Cho một cái viên
hạ sốt lô đít
lúc đấy đừng có pha gói
cái gói ấy mấy nó không có uống được đâu
phải là cái dạ đút đít nhá
cái dạ đút đít sau đấy nhét đít Cho em bé
nếu như mà bà chưa biết
cái hàm lượng phù hợp với cái số cân của bạn ý
thì comment Cho tôi biết tôi sẽ lên video Cho bà nhá
cái lưu ý quan trọng khi mà sơ cứu em bé bị sốt Cao
co giật đấy là SAO
không được nhét bất cứ một cái gì vào trong miệng của em bé
không được Cho Tay
hay là Cho cái gì vào trong miệng để sợ em bé cắn vào lưỡi
trong lúc mà em bé giật như thế
cái rưỡi cái lưỡi nó bị tụt vào trong
nó không có Ra ngoài đâu mà sợ em bé cắn vào
không được nhỏ chanh hay là nhỏ bất cứ một cái
thể loại gì vào trong miệng em bé cả
cứ để yên Cho em bé nó giật
sau hết năm phút là em bé nó sẽ trở lại bình thường
người nó sẽ mềm Ra và em bé nó sẽ ngủ được không còn
nếu mà hết năm phút mà không
nó không hết giật ấy
thì làm giống như tôi nói đưa em bé đến cơ